Matt Lauer makes his big on-camera
return well sort of
in heaven
that's the former Today Show anchor
lip-syncing on his daughter
Romy's tick-tock page the duo teamed up
for a series of videos for the social
media app each one featuring a seemingly
playful and light-hearted Lauer Maddon
Romi dancing to chance the rapper's hot
shower they also performed their own
rendition of big fun from Heather's the
musical flowers videos got mixed
reactions with one member commenting hmm
Matt that's where he ended up I was
wondering what happened after The Today
Show
now I know good morning welcome to today
on a Friday morning I'm Matt Lauer Lauer
has been keeping a low profile since
being fired from The Today Show
in late 2017 over accusations of
inappropriate sexual behavior as long as
my kids and our family and our friends
know the real story that's really all we
care about he was last spotted in August
supporting his daughter at the Hampton
Classic horse show alongside his now
ex-wife
Annette Roca the pair finalized their
divorce in September with Lauer agreeing
to pay about 20 million dollars in their
settlement a source previously told et
that he finally decided it was time to
finalize everything and move forward and
focus on the kids he has a lot of guilt
about how things went down and he wants
to make sure Annette is taken care of
of course the two who married in October
1998 share three kids together 18
year-old son Jack 15 year old daughter
Romi and 12 year old son ties
you